In a Moment of Vision...
It's 1762.
John Montagu is the 4th Earl of Sandwich,
a small parish in
the southwest of England.
Despite his keen administrative skills,
Montagu is a corrupt politician,
an adulterous husband,
and an incessant, degenerate gambler.
Often, while Montagu is in the midst
of a particularly high-stakes game,
he will insist on being served
his meals at the table.
In a moment of vision,
though likely inspired by his travels,
the Earl orders his meat and cheese
be brought to him
stacked between two slices of bread
so that he may eat with one hand
while continuing to gamble with the other.
In one notorious episode, Montagu
spends a full day and night gambling.
It is during the infamous 24 hours
at the gaming table
that Montagu's characteristic handheld
concession is dubbed "the sandwich."
According to one estimate,
Americans now consume more than
300 million sandwiches every day.